yeah mof let's start with that search
you did you were looking so tell the
tell the lovely people what it was that
you were doing and why you came across
this yeah so we have you know
conversations among guys in the group
and specifically in the general to about
different things and one of the things
that's recently come up is
how know people people like to rail on a
lot about life being hard for men and
while you know there's no disagreement
there for the most part but it's still
easier to be alive and live than it ever
has before I mean you can waste your
entire life away comfortable on a couch
playing video games eating Cheetos like
you can do all that it's easy you can do
that right now you could do that
tomorrow for the rest of your life that
you could just make that the next 40 or
50 years um now I mean when you want to
talk about long-term success and
building a legacy and something you're
actually happy with you probably
wouldn't be coming out the other side um
the way you'd want to but so we talk a
lot about we kind of live in an age now
where guys have to for Force themselves
to do hard things to grow or guys that
want to get better results have to go
through adversity and have to put
literally sometimes have to put
obstacles in their way to get better
results out of life and so you know just
kind of on a whim
and um trying to think about some things
that I could potentially do and things
that I could get involved with to get
through some adversity or try to try to
face up some so I came across this list
of I think the the Google search and
anybody can find this I just I just
searched three three words challenges
for met and the first thing came up was
this list of a hundred tough things
every guy should do and I think why this
is relevant is because anybody can
search this and any guy out there that's
looking for challenges or looking for
things to do to make themselves better
is going to run into information like
this um so I can share a couple of these
rich I don't know if you want to talk
about some of the ones yeah thr up the
stream so is that the ask men one that
says 100 tough things every guy should
do yes it is number one result where I'm
sitting too number Prett much North
America now number one result right and
this is I don't know much about the
editors or askmen folks but I think
there's it's it's kind of a they sneak
some things in here that are like insane
so there's something that it makes sense
a compete in a race cool language right
learn to drive and then number seven
just buy a sex toy all right get lube
and stimulate your pro prostate
basically so when it comes to male sex
toys these days a Fleshlight is too
obvious of a choice just SP more than
single dime on your sex life what do you
do and get lube a sexy blindfold a
prostate stimulat so shove something up
your ass basically
basically yeah that's that's the advice
of ask men all right what else we got
and then they've got things like getting
a fight which is like okay good cool all
for it right I dig that yeah and then
but if you're straight
yeah therapy hang on what's the
experiment sexually whatever you
sexually whatever your sexual if you're
straight it wouldn't hurt to try
something new whether that is hooking up
with somebody unexpected jerking off to
a different kind of porn or some yeah
okay yeah they're like basically telling
you to be buyer weird uh therapy
considering hang on go back up yeah uh
considering a man me means being pushed
make it bigger again or my [__]
eyesight sucks I don't know what's going
on
here yeah there you go being being a
mench why is it throwing Jewish language
in there being a mench you see mench
being I see being man right here no
below being a mench
Meen mentioned in in the Jewish culture
means being a good guy yeah means means
being taken care of your [__] quit being
a coward and talk to a professional
about you quit quit being a coward and
go pay somebody a few hundred bucks to
tell you that you're a [__] and your
masculinity is toxic I don't know if you
guys know this but the APA a few years
ago put out a bulletin to all therapists
that are licensed under them telling
them to treat all masculinity as toxic
and basically gave him a list of ways to
uh tell men to stop being so men and um
masculine I'll tell you this right now I
put it on out on Twitter the other day I
said look stop wasting your money on
therapy one of the best things you can
do is go find a I mean they're not
licensed obviously but somebody that
knows what the [__] they're doing and
take you through like a full Heroes trip
on soloc mushrooms you will deal with
whatever Darkness you have whatever you
have as long as you enter it with proper
intention and it's properly facilitated
you'll get years of therapy done within
like five hours very easily therapy for
most guys is a always say either that or
just spend a few hours watching a bunch
of the videos on my channel like on
topics that are relevant to you they'll
answer a lot of
questions considering therapy yeah keep
going that's only 13 and we've already
seen a couple of dumb ones in the top 13
right there's more coming change your
diet go vegetarian or go vegan no thanks
I'm
good fix something broken okay work with
your hands good travel far good own up
to something okay that's accountability
good take care of a pet all right
educate yourself on
consent one of the most now and then
they sneak one in that's like yeah it's
like every fifth one let's throw in some
[__] to make people like weak right
being being able to talk and respect
boundaries it's simple she says no fine
just go next next you don't need to
educate yourself in some stupid uh make
an expected friend learn to cook yeah
okay make someone yeah okay uh someone
though not a woman someone not a woman
someone yeah of course make sure it's
just someone yeah uh speak out against
hate that's so stupid guys like there's
always going to be people you like and
you don't
like decorate your own space okay well
that's kind of fruity get in your own
get your inbox to zero oh yeah that's
really important as a guy like I I think
about that every day getting my inbox to
zero I got nothing better to do right
keep a journal get into female art why
why do I got to get into female artists
because is this like an advertisement
for so I think it is an advertisement
for
soy keep going develop a wardrobe okay
create a legacy sure post pasture
physical lits good own a perfectly
fitted suit absolutely I agree with that
pass up on tempting sex I mean sure if
you want to do K what the hell is K Mari
you don't have to read Marie condo's
book or watch Netflix series to
understand the impact of her work who
the hell is Marie condo and con Mary so
she did this thing I can't remember the
name of this show or the series but her
whole thing is she's she helps people
like get rid of unnecessary junk and
clutter they talk about you know
decluttering
your anti hoarding stuff like that um
yeah people that are like having a hard
time getting rid of stuff and Chach keys
that just like sitting around the house
and stuff like that yeah so decluttering
fine okay good make a bucket list sure
plant something okay give a wedding
speech yeah go on a hike yes raise a kid
sure demand a raise demand a raise
really on raise a child you see how they
they shame they find a way to shame guys
the first line of this is not have a
child as every guy can like don't be a
de be dad you piss piece of [__] right
not have a child sneak things in here
basically be a cuck and go and raise
some other dude's kit yeah there you go
I mean they didn't out overtly stated
but that's what they're implying well
babysitter tutor and teacher are
listenting so I mean demand a raise plan
a party no I'm good I let women plan on
parties uh find your scent what do you
need to find a scent for your body
already has a scent just wash it and
[__] go outside it's simple fall in
love that's going to happen by osmosis
if you like girls uh uh set yourself up
to fail forgive an
enemy eat your words develop a skincare
routine donate your body parts money is
not the only thing in life you can
donate think no I'm good I want my body
to be whole when I'm dead just bury in
the ground just [__] Fold It Up in a
pretzel and stick it in the ground I'm
good burn it I don't care expand your
Consciousness yes not here we go
meditating fasting life is short they
don't talk about a hero's trip though
say micro doing but Micro doing is light
I mean Heroes trip or DMT is like a
totally different game uh be extra
generous
sure encourage the vote yeah don't vote
for dumb [__] though
unfortunately uh contact your Democratic
Representatives why they don't [__]
listen to you it's pointless make some
art seek medical attention you know what
the whole seeking medical attention
thing man I've changed my view on that a
lot it's like I don't need the F like if
I break a bone we go to a doctor I'm not
going to ask the opinion of a regular
like practitioning doctor on on health
or because most of them are just so
influenced and biased towards [__]
prescribing [__] I mean we have a mutual
friend um you know 50 knows him um you
know his mother died recently and uh he
was going through her medical records
and she was prescribed something like 18
or 19 different medications she took the
took the jab like seven times or some
[__] like that no uh tell somebody the
painful truth yes be [__] honest
absolutely DIY something yeah we're
halfway
there uh build a book collection yeah
help a stranger okay go through go
through with a romantic
gesture okay uh trace your lineage sure
try a kin F yeah cross oh there it is
there's the one there it is crossdress
life is Richard when you see other
perspectives like what to wear high
heels how much work yeah this is uh this
is is an advertisement for soy number 62
is all about
soy yeah well it's funny because you
know show the world you're comfortable
with your manist and dress as a woman
then the next step up from that is show
the world that you're comfortable with
your heterosexuality and go blow a dude
yeah look if you want to do number 62
and crossdress go do it have fun I want
you to eat you're just never going to
sit at my table
bro uh cut somebody toxic out of your
life yes develop a skill yes take a
social Med a break yes challenge your
own mindset yes sand a handwritten
letter sure boycott a brand okay 69 with
someone someone not a woman again not a
chick someone just someone yeah anyone
go cold turkey on an addiction
absolutely you should make anything that
you're that you're strongly drawn to uh
your [__] should be able to walk away
from it smoking sugar alcohol weed
whatever happens to be should walk away
from anything what do you got there Zen
oh yeah you're down to the nicotine eh
um I tried that down in Florida and I
just I just didn't like it man it
[__] it practically burned in my
mouth reconnect with somebody
okay develop a signature meal yes get a
gym membership and [__] use it by the
way uh get to know somebody with a
different sexuality I mean sure I know a
couple of gay dudes and you know they're
somewhat interesting to have a
conversation with them just you know
whatever uh own a watch fulfill
someone's fantasy donate what you don't
need make someone feel valued thank you
parents make life easier for disabled
people cry in public here we go there we
go one of the bravest things you can do
as a guy is be vulnerable yeah because
chicks like that they love [__] dudes
that just cry like a little [__] cry at
the movies at a ball game when your
favorite team wins or the table of
dinner when you're going through a
breakup let it all out
man keep going are we done no dude we're
only at 82 let's see what else what
other how many is there 100 bite your
tongue take a masturbation break how
about just don't masturbate and instead
bang huh how about that because that's
what you've been [__] designed to do
not rub them out tell a tell your female
co-workers what you
make for a variety of reasons women are
often paid less than men for the same
work no they're not it's been covered a
million [__] times William women
choose jobs overwhelmingly that are that
require less hours and less pay than men
women in the exact same jobs as men get
paid the exact same [__] pay it's
been proven a million times over [__]
84 eat a dick do something with your
body hair sure wax it shave it eat it I
don't care wingman a friend build a
website dance confront sexual harassment
sexual misbehavior thrives when
bystanders don't do anything okay
comfort someone through a tough time
modify your body oh here we go get an
earring nose ring or a tongue
piercing hey MF are you gonna get a
tongue piercing not under the penalty of
death entire point the entire point of a
tongue piercing as women know it is to
blow you with that thing on their tongue
that is it so that is some gay stuff
right there ask
men keep a secret for someone do karaoke
kill an animal and eat it I agree with
94 100% uh get a museum membership okay
confront your racial prejudices go for
jury duty pick up litter okay so there
it is they save it for last Sak it in
it's like every sixth to 10th one
they've you know they throw some soy in
there trans people don't have it easy if
you were born okay whatever I mean this
is YouTube so we're going to skip that
come up with your own definition of
being a man it's not this [__] list I
can tell you this you know what this
list feels like like a an editor that's
a human being a man made it and then a
committee came and said this is not
woken up you got to throw 10 10 of these
other ones in there to make sure it's
like it's not even written in the same I
don't know um vein right okay is it
possible to take this and just edit it
for a 1% version and publish it they'll
probably it'll probably Whittle down to
70 from 100 we should actually you know
what that is a great idea we should have
a list of requ requirements for the
membership of our community to maintain
membership I [__] love that idea
let's let's put it together and you know
what I'm going to publish it I'm going
to put it on the website yeah do publish
the damn thing let's uh just just edit
it it was great great job finding it MF
and just just take all the damn saw out
of it and um you know what I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna put the list out I'm
gonna edit it and then I'm gonna pay
somebody to SEO optimize it so it can
push this dog [__] down to the bottom of
Google how how about that how about them
apples I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the ful
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out